elle et participe à des concours vous de
voter bah quoi à mon insu certains quand
j'étais jeune ma ma soeur me trouvais
très beau quand j'avais 18 ans et 17 18
ans j'ai apporté une photo de maïwenn
est certainement très détaillée du coup
elle avait acheté un appareil photo emma
est pris en photo mais fait poser soi
disant parce qu'elle avait un nouvel
appareil photo que je m'étais prêté de
bonne grâce à ogeu descendent le dire
elle va envoyer ça au magazine 20 ans je
passe il existe des jo c'était le
concours du plus du plus beau plus beaux
modèles de france à l'espoir mannequin
de france et gtl et au final nous on est
obligé d'aller et venir à paris c'est
énorme nema province nous habite epinal
dans les vosges
non j'étais à monter à paris j'ai passé
un casting avec des gens franchement je
n'ai aucune envie j'ai encore des petits
boutons d'acné tous étaient périmés non
ils ont vu que j'étais pas très motivés
dont j'ai pété prime il s'était quand
même photo dans 20 ans essayer de
retrouver ma carrière de mannequin elite
model look et j'ai été éliminée -
bientôt en demi finale mais en
contrepartie j'ai pu rentrer chez les
lites à new york
[Musique]
berck lagarde et notamment la guerre sa
première sa première dauphine c'est
joséphine de beauharnais
oui oui qu'est-ce que vous ayez ou non
mais moi aussi c'est marrant parce que
j'ai été mannequin aussi comme jane est
plus jeune et
j'étais très jeune je devais avoir j'ai
pas 16 ans à l'époque et c'était une
copine qui avait envoyé mes photos
pareil chez élite et donc j'étais rentré
chez l'élite
oui moi j'ai des amis aussi qu'ils vont
envoyer les photos moche et guigou cbt
le bouledogue à ses côtés d'une mine il
a dit oui oui
non non ça intéresse personne mais j'ai
fait il fait des photos de mode aussi à
l'époque s'y intéressent pas défini pour
paco rabanne morts oui aussi quoi ta
difficile pour toi conte rabanne j'ai
défilé pour paco rabanne oui et kenzo
aussi été mis en place sur la plage et
mais quand même ça veut dire que vous
avez des chroniqueurs qui ont voté oui
j'ai défilé pour kenzo est pas prête à
défiler dans la rue cauzit tour du
leader
j'ai paco rabanne la vertu
il est très beau très longtemps à
l'abandon avec tous les cas 25 ans mais
c'est bon c'est vrai c'était un plaisir
c'est une trouille ça fait peur des
défilés pour kid a rigolé pas que des
castings quoi passer à ça que des
castings casting du petit prix mais
nadal richard anconina ils m'ont appelé
c'est tellement appris casting de 6 pacs
avec richard anconina ils m'ont rappelé
à la sortie du collège
ils m'ont pas pris 8 14 ans qui avec
johnny hallyday la série j'ai fait le
casting rue marbeuf
ils m'ont pas pris casting de ip5
dernier mais en même temps dans l'art
garni m'ont attrapé dans la rue monde il
faut que tu fasses du cinéma ils m'ont
pas pris on gaspille de braquo avec un
tabac si je livrais olivier marchal 6
heures du matin j'en ai parlé avec lui
il avait un coup dans l'aisne il m'a dit
faut que tu ailles à son bourg saint
denis à ma boîte de prod toi tu vas
faire du cinéma
j'étais je les adore olive et j'étais
faubourg 5 thomas braquo et m'ont pas
pris
c'est que ça fait qu'à 20 ans je me fous
de cinéma il ya de gueule du cinéma
moi je te dis la vérité je verrai grave
travaillait dans un cinéma
[Applaudissements]